عقد في العاصمه البريطانيه لندن مؤتمر
صحفي لتقديم نزال الملاكمه الذي يجمع بين
البريطانيه
سيقام هذا النزال في العاصمه السعوديه 28
من الشهر المقبل ضمن فعاليات موسم الرياض
في نسخه الرابعه البريطانيه هو بطل العالم
في فئه الوزن الثقيل وفقا لتصنيف المجلس
العالمي للملاكمه اما الكاميروني فهو بطل
وفاه الوزن الثقيل السابق في اتحادي يو اف
سي للفنون القتاليه المختلطه
هذه المباراه مختلفه تماما وستكون صعبه
للغايه مختلفه لانها رياضه لم امارسها
بشكل احترافي من قبل لقد مارستم ملاكمه في
الماضي كهاون وهذا اكثر ما يثير اهتمامي
اسال نفسي ماذا سيحدث اذا ذهبت الى الرياض
ووجهت لفيوري ضربه قاضيه المخاطره كبيره
ولكن اذا نجحت فالمكافاه اكبر